both of our personalities we like to do
things our way
um
but we also are very aware that ego and
greed would be our biggest downfall so
if we really hold on to needing to be
right or wanting to break too much so
i think the thing we've done really well
so far and we continue to do is just we
always look for what's right so if it's
my idea kevin's idea someone else's on
the team
we welcome
disagreements and
we love to argue with each other because
we get better outcomes from it all
i think the thing we do really well is
we just look for what makes sense and
what seems right versus oh i need to
hold on to this opinion because it was
my own
so is there a process did is there a
process to a disagreement yeah it's very
organic and i think to mass clinic we
encourage principal disagreement amongst
the team you know for i think the magic
kind of happens in the middle of of that
and it's just i think it's from our
athletic background just being kind of
innate and growth in us um
and it's kind of transferred and come
through a beam too
this podcast exists because i love
talking to people and i love going deep
the purpose is to plant seeds of
inspiration we enter a space of
vulnerability and relatability and what
you realize is that we are so much more
alike than we are different to quote
ramdas we're all just walking each other
home and this show is just one step i'm
danica patrick and i'm pretty intense
today on the show
are a couple of friends
matt lombardi and kevin moran they
started a company called beam which is a
company that i have invested into as
well as promote and we've become friends
and
i just thought they would be such an
interesting interview from a business
entrepreneurial standpoint and startup
in particular we talked about
what makes it
hard and and i'm saying that because
most of it is hard at this point in time
what we also talked about was the their
mindset and where they came from
and how it's just almost being repeated
in a different
platform so they both were athletes
hockey and baseball
and very good and then when those
careers ended they both felt like they
just wanted to excel at something else
and so
here comes beam and so they work
together really well they're building a
big team they just had their first
retreat where everyone got together and
you know they were able to build the
rapport and and they're really really
building this huge company they just
have really great nuggets about what it
takes to be successful the fact that
it's not all glitz and glam that there's
a lot of you know elbow grease and a lot
of sweat that goes into it it's about
having a vision and it's about having
the mindset to get around it and then we
talked also about their own mental
health and just what it takes for them
to stay balanced
and of course then how they take care of
all their employees great friends
amazing product enjoy the episode so uh
you started off by saying that you
bicker a lot what do you bicker about
what is there pretty much everything
what is it
about pretty much any idea strategy
professional life personal life related
things we launch lunch
running a business together
is
hard i mean it's hard when there's not
just like one person that's the dictator
and having two people it's you know i'm
sure it can be
a little challenging was there times
where it was more
challenging than it is now or would you
say that it's always kind of this
ongoing process of like
i it's
saying that someone i follow new level
new devil like you guys as you continue
to grow new problems crop up so
therefore
new new reasons to bicker crop up is it
true is the trajectory getting better or
is it just kind of the way it goes when
you're running a big business and you've
got two
smart guys with a lot of ambition we're
not that smart
my response that would be
both of our personalities we like to do
things our way
but we also are very aware that ego and
greed would be our biggest downfall so
we really hold on to needing to be right
or wanting to break too much so
i think the thing we've done really well
so far and we continue to do is just we
always look for what's right so if it's
my idea kevin's idea someone else is on
the team
we welcome
disagreements and
we love to argue with each other because
we get better outcomes from it all um
i think the thing we do really well is
we just look for what makes sense and
what seems right versus oh i need to
hold on to this opinion because it was
my own
so is there a process
is there a process to a disagreement
there's just a lot honestly i've always
wondered that's cute it's really um
it's really not yeah it's very organic
and i think to match point we encourage
principal disagreement amongst the team
you know for i think the magic kind of
happens in the middle of of that
um and it's just i think it's from our
athletic background just being kind of
innate and growth in us um
and it's kind of transferred and come
through a beam too
well that gets back to what i was
actually thinking is that of course i've
known you guys for years and
um you know we i would call as friends
um
but i don't know how you guys met
about 10 years ago so we went to boston
college together um kevin played
baseball at bcs you know i played hockey
bc and
i guess we met we had a few classes
together um we joke i think there's a
few professors that would find it
we have a hello i wanna
why not it's just us
because it's really embarrassing because
some of our other investors might listen
to this and yeah and uh
that could be the end
uh we did a i'll just put it to you like
this we did a very very very very poor
job in front of a group of people uh in
a group project and
i've done a lot of embarrassing things
in my life and
that still is top of the list for most
modifying it
was it so you connected on this very
embarrassing thing
or you did it together
yeah i guess this really is how we
really met i mean we've seen each other
just you know in the athletic weight
room in the locker rooms and stuff like
that we're only friends though in
college very much yeah but somehow we
wound up in a marketing class together
we ended up in a group together so a few
of my teammates a couple of kevin's
teammates we were entering playoffs
their season was just starting so they
were traveling up and down the coast we
were
you know heading to the final stretch of
our season
this project really wasn't top of mind
for either of us and the whole semester
the whole thing was based on helping a
business with whatever it is i think we
got paired up with the insurance company
and we're supposed to just essentially
like free interns
we never communicated all to that
company um and we showed up on the
presentation day and we played a clip
from the an opposition remember hold on
one guy on the baseball team we've met
one day before he's just like okay i got
this i know what we're going to do oh
great i thought i was going to be here
for a few hours cramming for this so we
show up and he plays a video clip of the
office and there's like four or five of
us and we just this is like a
i don't know like a marketing election
uh yeah stadium seating in the class so
he plays a clip of the office and all
this it ends and we stare at each other
they were like
are you gonna you're gonna keep talking
about you said you got it and just
nothing we all just stared at each other
and
you know like that like giggling feeling
that you can't control when you're just
like totally mortified it just came over
everybody the whole class just beating
down staring at us and
that's how we met
so you were you were doing a
presentation together yeah you could
call it that
got it got it and
matt you played
baseball hockey hockey i played baseball
and that was my junior year and i
i didn't i got drafted that year and i
wasn't
i didn't end up coming back from my
senior year i did later in life um
graduated but at that point in my life i
wasn't very concerned about my grades
well
you and like every other kid in the
world at some points at least in time
yeah it probably all depended on if a
parent cared about their grades because
if you left it up to the kid to care
about the grades
it's probably few and far between
i already agree with that yeah did you
guys think that you were going on to be
athletes is that part of it yeah that
was it for me i knew i was gonna get
drafted that year and i had a pretty
good understanding that i wasn't going
to come back to school for my senior
year right away so
yeah it was like i said it was it wasn't
but it definitely never wasn't number
one on my list but it probably wasn't
number two three four or five either in
terms of priorities so then what was it
about because like that was
cop that was college
right
and then
you know beam is only
three or four years how many how many
years has been been around three just
about two and a half coming up on three
hundred
so you know i'm i'm not judging but you
guys didn't just get out of college
but so like what happened what happened
in college during this presentation that
you all connected on
that then led to starting beam was there
something that was it didn't have to do
with
um supplementation and experimentation
within sports as it went along did you
stay connected did you
um
traveling this brotherhood of pants or
something i mean like how did you guys
stay it was kind of
it was kind of just serendipitous we
didn't keep in touch at all when kevin
left we both played professional for a
little bit
um wound up out of sports sooner than we
were hoping because of injuries and
we just crossed past an apartment
building in boston that we just wound up
and bumped into each other to the
elevator and then seriously kevin i just
haven't yeah i actually had this crazy
store my wife and i we lived in austin
should my
girlfriend at the time then fiance moved
back to boston
and we were gone for a long week and i
won't bore you with the details of the
story i got a call like on a sunday
afternoon that was like hey um there's
two feet of standing water in your tent
you're ten uh
in the apartment on your tenth floor we
had all of our crap was ruined we had to
move out of the apartment immediately
and i moved into that building where
matt was in the seaport um if that
didn't happen we probably wouldn't be
here either yeah that was a serendipity
over there
and then we just love all things
wellness and we started working out
together and
i totally want to ask about that um
because you both i mean matt you're more
into crossfit and lifting and kevin
you're a little more like endurance and
cardio stuff we did we did connect on
the crossfit stuff in the very beginning
um for sure in telling me that story
i've
i've had a lot of thoughts about this
where the universe just kind of sends
you signs all the time right and if we
pay attention there um
and i do think that people
stay in our path that are meant to be
there and sometimes there's these near
misses where you see them
or where you don't see them but you're
at the same place same time like maybe
you could have had the story where you
were you lived in the same building you
didn't even know it but i don't know
something tells me that this kind of was
always meant to be because
you know you had this random
presentation in college you didn't even
stay in touch all of a sudden you see
each other in the elevator and
and so maybe it wasn't a conscious
synchronistic event or maybe it was i
mean how did you what what happened when
you saw each other after so long of not
staying connected
that uh what what did you do when you
saw each other
i think the first thing we did you were
training for an iron man with brook and
we worked out together um
that's a great story too actually yeah
we were uh i was i was trained brooke
and i were training for what was that uh
you're welcome
yeah my wife brooke yeah yeah uh for
iron man mondragon blonde uh because
this is probably like
16 yeah 2015. and um
we went deep in a very hard training
block where you're doing like
i don't know a lot of a lot of hours of
cardio on a weekly basis and one of the
workouts i'm sure you've probably done a
fart like danica where you're doing five
have you done those before yeah five
fourth a fartlek um
yeah it's kind of an interesting name
it's it's a part i'm a girl it's
actually it's it's swedish for speed
play so it's like a five minute effort
at like extra pace two minutes easy four
minute effort at wide pace two minutes a
little bit harder harder harder the
effort gets shorter but harder i mean
i've done structures like that but i
haven't yeah so you haven't called it a
fart like though
no i just called it interval training
um
so we had a big fire like coming up and
uh we matt it was like hey i'll join you
on this workout i remember being like
dude
no with love and respect i don't know if
this is the one you want to just like
hop in and on if you're a big brother is
he as buff as he is now totally oh yeah
maybe maybe not quite as big as he is
now i haven't gotten into crossfit yet
so i wasn't he was like he wasn't in
marathon he didn't look like a marathon
right now we'll call him um
did he join me he hung on for
like 90 of it
um i remember i got back and brooke and
i were like damn that was like what a
what a savage that was like you have to
be a freak to be able to to deal with
that and i couldn't do anything for
about a month after that
an impromptu bartlett to know your knees
but i think that like cemented like i
think matt and i like you know it's
a startup is really hard you know
there's
you spend your whole day your every week
and moment of your day getting kicked in
teeth and i think like that kind of for
me it was like a good indication of like
all right this person has like that
either has one or is missing that extra
chromosome to be able to do like this
like this craziness you know
yeah there's always been something just
like
the bond i guess through working out
with summoner training even in hockey
like some of my best relationships have
come through the guys you know i do
extra workouts with or we go do some
extra stuff with them with kevin
i think that's kind of your point like
why we you know we connected back like
what was it that all of a sudden
you know we have other close friends let
me start a company with them um we love
them all dearly too but i think there's
something probably just like that
shared experience of software together i
think
for athletics too when people stop
playing like i think professional sports
to an extent like they they get uh maybe
less discipline or less uh focus i would
say like for both of us like i think
there may be some unfinished business to
an extent so i think um
like our vision got tighter and like our
discipline got tighter and more focused
and i think that led to this i mean
um
yeah
why do you think that is that your
vision became more focused well i know
for me i you know i
had a lot of injuries i blew out my knee
i had tommy john's surgery i tore my
rotator cuff from my labrum my shoulder
and pretty much every injury a baseball
player in the picture could have so
is that right
you were a pitcher yeah yeah it was a
closing picture
um
so i looked back at it you know when i
got drafted i was expecting to play for
a lot of years it's had to be like my
life my identity and all the things that
are associated with that and how did you
pitch what was your how fast oh i
couldn't i could get off into the high
90s without pretty hard
yeah it was it was uh i don't know about
today but i was uh back in the day i
could and i think like i always
associated with like that being who i
was what my identity was going to be and
it got
to an extent i would say taken away from
me from no fault of my own you know i
worked as hard as anybody and um you
know the bounces just didn't happen
where they were supposed to so i think
like on the other side of that
i just felt like you know maybe i need
to go get down do my own thing or i need
to like
somehow make up for that um make up the
two things that i picked girl yeah i
don't i don't know what it was i don't
know if makeup works the right way work
the right word but
do something to kind of like redeem that
experience or what i feel like taking
away from me could also be especially
because of the sustainability of this
effort that you experienced young
through college beyond until now
uh is that it's maybe it wasn't so much
of a of a of a make up for it as much as
uh redirect it
because
always there so it was like what do i do
with this drive this purpose this need
to be successful and excel
and where can i put that energy now
yeah and i went through like a period of
time so after baseball i worked for a
big tech company for about five or six
years and i went through a period of
time where like life was fulfilling and
exciting right but it wasn't like
didn't it didn't like have that like all
on the line feeling like you have as a
closing picture and you do as
entrepreneurs so i was i was happy i was
very fulfilled but i wasn't i was like
miscast in a way what about you matt did
you
i mean what ended what what why did you
stop hockey and then and then and what
were the feelings around that because
any time we lose something i mean this
is speaking to everyone where there's
like big transitions and things that you
become very attached to and
things that are pa you know you you you
have this vision whether it's a job or a
place you live or relationships like we
get this imagination for what it's going
to be and then when it's not there's a
there's a breakup there's a dissolving
there's a there's a there's a big shift
so how did that go for you it was hard
at first i i had a really bad concussion
my last year playing i played the miners
for a few years and got whacked in the
head pretty hard and realized i had
probably more concussions than i
was aware were acknowledged at the time
um
and i think
what you did this i made a lot of sense
to annika too just like i had a lot of
work ethic and drive and ambition and
passion and then for me it was always so
easy i could go
shoot pucks i could get on the ice i
could work out and i could just do it
all day long it was very easy to
to fulfill that all the passion work
ethic and all that stuff it's easy for
me to do that in a physical sense and
then i think the hardest part one of the
hard things that i just had to
transition was like how do i use my my
brain essentially the way i was able to
use my body it was really easy again
just to put in hours and hours of
practice what does that look like as an
entrepreneur it's a lot of just like
sitting there and thinking reading
listening to podcasts networking picking
people's brains
learning from other entrepreneurs and
businesses that was it was hard to
figure out how to
use my my brain muscle i guess and then
the other thing
was just i wanted to play the nhl i
didn't quite get there i had a
successful collegiate career um
and
you know a lot of it was understanding
like why would i actually want to play
in the nhl and kind of unpacking that a
little bit and realizing i can still
i realize i can achieve all those things
and more now as an entrepreneur it
wasn't so much about the actual game of
hockey it was it lit me up i was
passionate about it i could create a
certain lifestyle from it i loved what i
did i loved the process of it
once i realized entrepreneurship could
give me that that then i sort of was
able to move on from hockey and you know
find other things that i could sink my
time into
that being what what did you get from
that being hockey that you realized you
could get from being an entrepreneur
doing something else
just the lifestyle they want to create
um one of the things is just financial
freedom you can do that in hockey you
obviously do as an entrepreneur
um hockey gave me a sense of fulfillment
just passion i love the process of being
a hockey player i equally or if not more
now i love the process of an
entrepreneur like what it is to
start a company and hopefully have a
successful ending to it and everything
in between that um there's a lot of
parallels the way i correlated it that i
could just it just really is like the
process and the journey of
trying to achieve and accomplish
something it's kind of like a never
ending like constantly trying to get
better and i didn't find this when i
first stopped playing i worked in at a
financial firm and i didn't find that
like sort of in the corporate role i
didn't find sort of that fulfillment
that passion where
you know i could feel the same emotions
and gratification from that
yeah
you must feel the same thing to an
extent i don't know what you're talking
about no um
i mean i got to do my sport i got to do
my sport for 27 years so
you know i think that and it was my
decision to be done and so
i do think that there's a difference it
doesn't mean that there's not still a
reorientation of
what it is that your purpose is
um
and what keeps you fulfilled i
definitely realize that what i loved
about racing was getting outside of my
comfort zone and pushing that all the
time i thought i hated it i actually
thought that i was kind of scared and i
was i was i'm such a methodical driver
that i would i wasn't the kind of driver
would just get in and go flat through
one and two first lap and you know i'm
just making up words and make sense to
anyone that was a race car driver but i
didn't have that over over achieving
you know
could end in tragedy kind of mentality i
was very methodical so i thought that
the the danger and the challenge it
wasn't the danger it was the challenge
it was like the
the the discomfort i i thought the
discomfort was something i didn't like
that i just had to kind of butt up
against but when i finished racing i
realized that it's the discomfort that i
really seek and um so now i've found
myself doing things like you know
learning how to do everything from like
skiing and snowboarding to wake surfing
to
you know bungee jumping and jumping out
of helicopters and skydiving every and
and even just doing interviews or you
know whatever else um i've realized that
i i'd like to do things that get me
uncomfortable so um was there something
that you similarly realized about what
you were doing um
before versus what you're doing what you
led into that you realized that you
loved about it so much like for me it
was that discomfort i liked pushing it
did you were you able to isolate some
aspect of it that that you that you
really loved
i think it was um you know we just
talked about this at our being retreat
lloyd asked this is a deep question but
yes what's the
we did a
couple hour long thing with the whole
team and the last prompt and the
questions was uh what is the purpose of
life um what's your purpose great
question i'd love for you guys to answer
that
what what i'm you know i thought about
it like 15 minutes and i kind of settled
on i i think well first of all i think
it changes over the course of your life
as you become a different person um
right and i think there's a difference
between the purpose of life and your
purpose of life
exactly
um
hearing you talk about after racing in
you and also myself i think
it's not the discomfort that i would
necessarily be seeking but i think it's
like the way that i answered that
question was maximize my potential and i
think you know it's not you know you
obviously you could do that in racing
but there are other areas in your life
that you'd want to maximize whether it
was skydiving or interviewing or
whatever it is i feel like
um for me with baseball maybe that was
the unfinished business that's why i
started doing iron man which is like i
have no business doing iron man the two
and a half mile swim 112 mile bike and
then a marathon but i knew i don't know
why i wanted to do that but when i
connect the dots looking backwards i
think it's because i want to max my
potential when i look at
this journey and how hard this has been
you really would have to be insane to
want to do this willingly this is not
very fun what we're doing to be honest
um
but what i think i hope on the other
side of it is what i know i'm doing on a
daily basis it's like maximizing my
potential every everywhere i can um
i think that's what the purpose is for
me now maybe the last question
maybe at the end we'll ask what you know
your purpose of life is but go ahead
something that you you recognized
yeah yeah it was always um just to
inspire their journeys about others it's
something that's always just got me
excited motivated me i think
probably if it's always had a little bit
of underdog story through sports and
even you know becoming an entrepreneur
and things that we're doing a theme and
you know dealing with challenging times
you know
building being now like wanting to
leverage that so not just if you want to
be an athlete entrepreneur but like like
you said damage like everyone can relate
to
overcoming adversity and challenges and
things like that and
it's always helped me just to keep
focused on charging ahead just if my
story my journey of how i'm approaching
life or business personal etc
could be helpful to someone else um i
think that to me that's that's always
popped out is something that's really
important and that was definitely in my
mind as a hockey player was
you know i want my career to be
inspiring to a hockey player's career
now just more broadly speaking just like
the overall journey so kevin you alluded
to
the fact that what you're doing now with
beam and starting a company is in no way
really fun um and if anybody probably
knew how hard it was they wouldn't sign
up for it right um
uh so what i mean what surprised you
because i think there's such a there's
such an at least almost called like an
american dream to like start a company
and you know have your own freedoms not
only
from uh from a physical standpoint of
where you go and what you do but
financially so
what what shocked the [ __ ] out of you
about
running a company that you're like wow
i didn't see this coming
oh my god how long do you have there are
so many things um
high points
maybe something kind of early on maybe
even just kind of like there's probably
been phases or
sort of spans of time where there's been
a new thing that's cropped up so like
what what are like sort of like
beginning intermediate and current sort
of like oh my god i had no idea i was
gonna have to deal with this uh this is
more of it this isn't to deal with but
something that's like always been kind
of hit me and
shockingly in a good way is how
inspiring and humbling is that people
you know this is matt and i's idea and
clearly we have an affinity to it that
no one can really understand that other
people are coming here and like willing
to to be
um
kind of vote with their careers and
their salary and their own life and have
like this to believe it so much and have
so much conviction around it it's like
shocking to me that now there's you know
20-ish people that believe that same way
has always been kind of an interesting
thing for me it's like humbling
inspiring but also like to an extent
shocking um
that they have so much conviction you
know i'm sure you feel the same way yeah
so does that feel like a weight then
because that's not necessarily like a
challenge other than the fact that that
that it might come from a responsibility
standpoint of like wow they've
sacrificed i hope this works i want to
make sure they
you know are made whole in the end or
or are happy to be here
totally i think we
matt and i have like such an intense
obligation to make this successful for
um i'd say
equally our investors who have voted on
us with their dollars and with their
pocketbooks you being one of them um i
have this reoccurring dream where i'm at
a barbecue and
beams failed and all of our investors
are there and uh i have to go one by one
and tell them all that we've lost their
money so that's that's been a fun one um
i think it's not for you you want to
live like on a healthy level of paranoia
and optimism that's definitely the
paranoid side but also for the team i
feel like we i feel and i know you feel
the same way like an extremely intense
obligation to make this successful and
have this be not only the most
financially rewarding you know part of
their career but also we tell everybody
when we hire them that we want you to
come to beam and for this for you to get
over some fear you have or you know to
leave a better person and if we do one
without the other it's a failure too so
we both definitely feel that really
intense obligation in a lot of ways the
people that work with the company
i think it's just by design um
too like it's a very intense environment
by design we have very big goals and
ambitions and i just think when i was at
bc
it was i was lucky to play a really good
hockey program we won two national
championships we played and won my
freshman year lost and
but every year we played dc the
expectation was the international
championship like with that comes really
high expectations and we're not messing
around and we're not here to you know
screw around and
i think we've created that culture being
that we're here to win a championship it
means something a little bit different
there's no actual trophy at the end of
it but
with that expectation just comes to
really high pressure and really big
expectations that
i would say it's not hard to start a
business it's hard i think for what
we've created in our goals that i think
that's what's hard anyone can start a
business and just the process to doing
that and
and that doesn't take a whole lot um
it's like when you're with a group of
people and you're really trying to push
your limits and reach your potential
like you're talking about that's when it
that's when it's like it's actually not
that fun when you really look at it it
might look fun for the surface and you
look at social and like we sign new
partners and we do these things we
launch new products the packaging looks
good but
behind the scenes it's just insanely
stressful and i just correlated that
back when i was in college just like
those years when the championship were
trying to
like every living breathing thing you do
is geared towards winning that
championship and if you don't you you
feel horrible even if you had a pretty
good season but you don't get to the end
it doesn't feel good so yeah it's
similar to sports you know there's two
danica like i in my athletic it's you
sacrifice a lot as an entrepreneur you
did it i did when i was playing sports
too there were a lot of weddings and my
life was very different um
because i chose that path and yours very
much the same and
starting a beam is the same thing you
just you have to sacrifice things that
ultimately a lot of people don't want to
sacrifice
what do you feel like it's
um taken
from each of you to
get to where you're at as far as like a
person and and and the personality
um and having employees and and building
a company because i think that's a
probably a big part of going from just
starting it and being like hey bud you
want to do this yeah sure let's do this
and then you know it's just the two of
you but now all of a sudden you have
employees and people in balance and you
got to get how do you get the best out
of everyone so
i think that's hard
what have you what have you realized
this is really important to getting the
most out of people because obviously
that's something that you're doing to
grow at the rate you're growing so
there's a lot in that um there's so many
like micro details it's like how to work
with and manage people and try to do
that but i think
that sounds like you're asking it from
like a spiritual standpoint would it
would have been like my answer is almost
like
our souls
yeah yeah like you like given yours and
i think like with the people
like it's empathy people it sounds like
i think we are very intense by nature
and we push like super hard probably too
hard at times and break people to an
extent um
but i think just like being empathetic
and understanding when people are broken
everybody's you know sent us to you the
other day everybody's going has gone
through just like us included have gone
through things in their life that are
just traumatic and distribute as a
person and
i think where everybody is today there's
like a
version of whatever that they have going
on in their life so i think it just made
me
just i used to be a lot less empathetic
than i was before being now hearing
all these stories while people have
worked that worked for the company it's
just everybody's going to do something
and it's hard and um
they're just doing the best to get
through it um yeah so i think just kind
of like meeting them in that place is
helpful
well i mean mental health is like topic
number one these days when it comes to
pushing and pushing to an elite level
whether it's in sports totally which
we've seen so much lately or uh in
business and so
um
what are your feelings around that how
do you how do you create an environment
that
that allows for people to
um
open up or allows people to
you know be their best or you know
days off okay or mental health day is
okay or is it a matter of like having
regular
meetings with people
and you know we've talked about this
before but that vulnerability equating
your relatability and how you know
there's a lot of projections that happen
out there with people that are dealing
with things
i mean i've done it like everyone is
guilty of doing that where we have
things going on and then somebody
somebody says something like what what
did you say you know you're short
because they haven't you have no idea
what battles they're facing so how do
you create an environment where it's
safe to safe to be honest and also
encourages that communication because
there's so much around the concept of
community being one of the most
healthy things that we
the one of the most healthy things we
can do for ourselves is community and
community includes i think a lot of
communication
i think one is we just try to lead by
example um especially from a
vulnerability standpoint i think kevin
and i are vulnerable with the team so it
opens the door for them to be vulnerable
back to us um
and then i would say just a really
simplistic thing is we have monthly
check-ins with everybody in the team
sometimes bi-weekly we're always just
very accessible and we always just talk
to everybody but
it we just ask and i think we ask in a
pretty sincere way you know how are you
doing not
in beam's world like how are you doing
personally what's going on in your world
and what's going on in life and
i think because we've been vulnerable
the team before and we continue to
encourage just open direct communication
that people feel comfortable to share um
so i try to just become the exercise of
just practicing asking questions and
asking people about how they're doing
personally i think over time too we you
people you build trust with how you how
you act in certain moments so to matt's
point i think
like when we have an opportunity to
build that trust with someone and say
the right thing or do the right thing or
be vulnerable back we
historically do it takes people
different
you know times to get there with each of
us um
i think it's just just showing it um
yeah and just being human back well how
do you guys do it then because
you know it always starts at the top
like you said it's like demonstrating by
example so i'm sure you're not going to
someone that works for you and going
i'm breaking down and crying like i had
a horrible night and you know
whatever's going on i'm not saying it
would be a bad thing and i'm not saying
that i just think that's probably not
how you go about it so what do you do
like for the people out there that are
listening that um are the bosses or are
in charge of groups like what is the
process that you have to
encourage mental health and allow
yourself to sort of reach some level of
balance and homeostasis so that you can
have the endurance to keep going because
the startup world is mad and i mean
being uber elitely successful at
anything is pretty mad but i know that
from a startup world it's
it's all on your shoulders not only from
the workload but from the responsibility
standpoint of all the investors and the
employees so what the heck do you guys
do
one of our values is people first um we
always use the phrase too happy healthy
whole and
i guess this is more related to bean but
like one thing that we do is we
prioritize people's health and wellness
we have a health stipend where people
can buy a peloton or they can use that
towards the subscription to something
wellness related
we have a we don't have a vacation
policy meaning there's no
fixed amount of days that you can take
off we just encourage you to take it as
needed so if you need to take a mental
health day or you take a day off or two
weeks off
we really encourage people to prioritize
their health and wellness um
and then i think just more broadly i
think we share we share about our lives
with everybody we build personal
relationships just for more of like a
human standpoint that's probably more
relatable to everyone is
just we're human we don't try to come
off as perfect people because we're the
founders we are very raw and real with
people of our own personal lives and
stories and
[Music]
we also acknowledge like we're not
perfect we make dumb decisions and
you know we mentioned that we're just
human
yeah no say the same thing i don't think
we
i think we don't try to be anything that
we're not um i would also say like we're
probably the worst ones on the team with
having balance in our lives so um just
being
that we don't lead by example no no we
don't believe by example but also just
like you know acknowledging in front of
the team and saying how you guys can do
better than us because we really suck at
this like we look at
um the things we're going through in our
lives like we need to be better
ourselves um
so i think it's i don't know how else to
say it's like leading by example and
just um
i think when we have the opportunity to
to give someone that vulnerability back
we generally take it and then you guys
recently just took your first like group
trip
um because again you guys are only a
couple years old and you know at the
beginning i'm sure it was just you so
it's only been in more recent time that
you actually have you know what 20
people or so how many people
you guys had your first
what what do you want to call it a
retreat
yeah beam team retreat i think was uh
how did that go oh it's great it was a
lot of what you just said i think it
gave us the opportunity to connect with
people in person look them in the eye
and have a lot of those conversations so
i think
the the
covet era
made it more difficult and is making it
more difficult for people to open up and
do exactly what we've just been talking
about so
meeting with some of these people and
purchasing was definitely an opportunity
to get to know people more and to really
understand um
what makes them tick and how we can
really motivate them and what's exciting
for them because a lot of people it's
not money it's not you know there's a
lot of things that make people tick that
you wouldn't expect
so it's
um you know fulfillment or
um
a better sense of self there's so many
different things that are out there that
people want to get from this that
to me like i just never expected in the
beginning and really kind of like diving
down to the core of what it is is
helpful and how to create environment
and put them in places within the
company to allow them to do that to get
that fulfillment
if someone was thinking about starting a
company
what would you tell them based on a few
years of experience now and being in the
deep end honestly it's the hard answer
because there's so much stuff um one
thing i would say is if
don't just do it because you think you
should if you
really be thoughtful about it and if you
have like a burning edge inside you
which i know i didn't include you to too
mad like it's not going to go waste you
should itch it but i had a burning um
yeah i had a burning edge yeah
yes uh if you have something burning
inside of you
you should you should put it out
it's not going to go away
yeah i would just say like i think one
of the things i can't imagine to do this
without kevin from the very beginning
like there's sometimes they're solo
founders and
it can work and there's been companies
where you've seen it work but um it's
really really really hard and having
someone
it's not even so much just to have
someone to just so you can do more and
get more done it's really just like the
moments when things get really tough and
challenging you have someone who really
understands what you go through because
sharing with your friends and family
just
isn't that helpful because they're not
sitting in the seat with you and can
quite understand the emotion and the
drain and the challenges of it all and
i think that's one thing i probably
pulled away from this is like have a
really good co-founder or partner that
you can or two um that you can
do with one it's more fun and two it's
just like you need people to lean on and
you need to it's just so much more
and your values to that person yeah yeah
yeah i would say like i should have a
shared sense of values with that person
too um
also the last thing i would say on that
is trust your intuition in your own
opinion um because no one knows your
business better than you do and i think
there's been so many times where
there's been things we've done and like
in our gut it's like we should do it
this way and sometimes we've i think
we've gotten more we've been better at
trusting our gut but there's just
something to be said about like the
founders of the business they just have
like some intuition that um
i know people just don't understand
sometimes so to trust that and listen to
that maybe one of the fundamental
questions that i know i'm getting to
kind of late here
but
why cbd like how how did this become the
thing so it's funny like when we
reconnected and you you know what made
our bunch wrong we
gosh we were talking about doing
something together for a few years it
wasn't just like we stumbled upon seeing
video let's go do this together um we've
spent years we wanted to start a trash
company we're gonna there's a handful of
things usually wellness related trash is
the only one that was kind of an outlier
oh trash is important have you smelled
trash it's been around too long oh yeah
yeah
cycling and wellness for our planet
mother earth exactly yeah it's important
um we were training for the boston
marathon in 2018. we'll make it quick we
started reading about cbd where it's
just as confused as anybody is what the
heck it was how did it work does it get
you high um really skeptical they didn't
really trust the products we saw in the
market
wound up trying a few different products
some we found pretty profound benefits
with our own health benefits and
then we just started to look at the
space and read about the trends and
where the kind of wellness market was
going and
we just saw a huge category that was
just completely untouched which is we
always just talk about this space of
athletics and active lifestyle that
we've focused beam into and no one was
really bringing cbd into the masses or
really into more like a mainstream
supplement and we just saw an
opportunity pioneer beam as you know to
be a really friendly consumer-friendly
product that or company that
brought something like cbd to but didn't
really make it drug-like or medicinal or
you know all the misconceptions we kind
of we thought of ourselves as pioneers
in the early days because i've tried cbd
stuff before and i think there's also
hemp is another sort of version um
that was what you could more commonly
get in grocery stores or stores
or
cbd i don't even know can you sell cbd
everywhere
that's that's also a loaded question all
right
so
not really
yeah so
and and there's just a lot of stuff that
you don't notice like it doesn't really
you're like
it's kind of like taking a multivitamin
you're like does it work i don't know
um
but
but from the very beginning when i got
product to try
i was like wow
this stuff works
ferraris and lamborghinis like there's
there's multiple different types of
really actually this will resonate with
you better than anybody danica um i was
like you went to carson
uh yeah maybe i should uh there's
there's really great uh cars in the
world there's really great cbd in the
world right um
all the way down to i don't know what
would be the worst you know car you can
think of we probably shouldn't say that
out loud yeah exactly
you can't ever say the bad stuff you can
only exactly
cars that you just wouldn't want
there's cars that yeah that i wouldn't
want to drive um yeah you know that cbd
is in the market too um we source the
ferraris and the lamborghinis and we've
had an uncompromising
focus on quality which leads to really
efficacious great products and we do
that not just with the cbs in the
product but also the
magnesium the melatonin the rishi all
the other ingredients that are in there
to create the synergistic effect we have
a pretty um
different process that we go through on
our side with with our team
just down to whatever you know card and
ingredient you might you know this you
see me you might find in 7-eleven right
it's a different thing
you can get both you can get both cars
in in the market you can get both types
of cpd and ultimately it's up to the
consumer to um
figure out what kind of car they want to
drive and what they want to pay for it's
just more expensive
no it's not necessarily more expensive
it's grown to different um
it's grown you know it's it's higher
quality you know what's the difference
between a burger at mcdonald's and a
piece of grass-fed beef you know
how do you find them then
a lot i always say a lot of bad
conversations yeah oh
yeah a lot of uh we're usually pretty
tightly up about just our manufacturing
process because we've really gone to
steps to find who our partners are and
to put them through sort of our ringer
of quality assurance and everything so
you know it's visiting facilities it's
understanding all the nuts and bolts
that go into that we have max and art's
team who really speaks at lingo really
well so we
he goes well beyond you know our
knowledge in terms of like check you
know in terms like the machinery the
operations how they do stuff gmp
certified collecting all those things so
yeah there's a lot but we realized that
we're in a high skepticism low trust
space right off the bat like to your
point i've tried products that haven't
that haven't worked for me so yeah we
realized that in the beginning so i was
like how can what can we do to combat
that like you have the highest quality
products have the most stringent process
behind the scenes and
um
you know work can we work with people
like you and other great athletes um
that put a little a legitimate stamp on
the brand and what is a nano cbd versus
like
a cbd oil or cbd like empowered it's a
good question
yeah so nano just refers to nano
emulsification technology so essentially
all we do is we break down the particles
in the oil into
even smaller pieces or particles so that
it's more bioavailable in your body um
so there are other people who use
nanotechnology across all supplements um
but even within that there's also
varying degrees to actually what that
particle supplies is and
um
in our category we've
we've found someone who takes it to a
whole different particle size then again
just like the mainstream technology we
like small small particles yeah
that must be part of why it works so
well uh
good i'm happy for the nano the other
part and i remember years ago
which would have just been the beginning
but early on
it was about taking the product and and
also adding in other things you
mentioned reishi and
magnesium and alphinine and all kinds of
different things and so
melatonin
you name it you you've looked into the
adaptogen
other other other natural products to to
put with it who where did that idea come
from i was so excited to talk to you
guys about that because that's something
that i had implemented in my regimen
from ever forever ago i mean i probably
2000 and i don't even know 14 or 15 i
started taking adaptogens and so i was
super stoked about that and their
benefits are great i mean i i just
finally watched fanta fantastic fungi
and it's an amazing amazing dock
but you know one of the highlights was
him grabbing a huge chunk of reishi and
talking about you know the benefits of
it and how powerful of a mushroom it is
and stories in there about you know how
you know certain turkey tales cured his
mother was at least a part of curing his
mother from breast cancer and so anyway
uh where did that come from the idea to
add others before i want to ask what
what do you think what percentage of
americans i'm just i don't know i'm just
curious what you think know what
adaptogens are i i mean i think it's a
growing number but i'm not sure that
it's like you know i i think they'd be
like oh yeah i've heard of that what is
it i think about like sub 20 still my
listeners know what the heck it is now i
think they do i think i mean i've talked
about enough wellness i think if you're
seeking health and wellness and you're
listening then you probably have heard
of it but i think there's a lot of
there's a lot of middle america that
doesn't yeah
that doesn't really think there's a
reason to eat organic or to
have grass-fed or to um
take any kind of supplementation of
anything and so
i i think there's there's probably those
people too um but but i think that it's
it's only through these kinds of
conversations that people start to get
educated and learn the benefits and so
you know you take something that's
incredibly powerful i mean you're you're
solved i feel like i always say that
wrong it's solved right we're still
fighting internally about that i call it
whatever
the the topical formula that i use all
the time um there's no other supplements
in that other than basically whatever it
takes for it to slide on the skin
so there's no extra adaptogens or other
supplements in there and it works
magically so the cbd works magically but
now you pile on top of that all these
other things that are you know have so
much hi so much history thousands of
years of history of being used uh in
cultures as well as now the science
behind it
well i think we've just everything we've
done we've always tried to take a
simplistic approach and it can be really
hard to do that especially in the world
of cbd and things that are very
confusing to people um
we just realized that people are looking
for benefits and function not so much
like i just want to take cbd and there's
like why do you want to use cbd and cbd
has many things that it can help with
but we started to realize like what
those key benefits are those key
use cases that people are looking for
and so sleep as an example we said okay
why don't we just make a great sweet
product and so we're all things that
contribute to a great night's sleep
whether it's falling asleep staying
asleep waking up refreshed that's how
dream came to be and and then naming it
dream is also really simplistic versus
just listing a bunch of ingredients on
it and confusing people more i think
you know some of that came from you know
you go to air one or whole foods you
look at the adapted gym shelf
and there's tons of them and they just
kind of say the name of the adaptogen
they don't give much of a description as
to what it is and why to use it and
kind of you know kevin you mentioned
earlier just like the intuition i don't
think we're the only people that have
ever made a functional supplement before
i originated the idea but
i think one of our things that's served
us well is our intuition around
simplicity and understanding human needs
really just around benefits and function
not so much well i just want to take
research i just want to take cbd
and just the idea like really what are
the main needs that people have in their
lives to stay happy healthy whole and
one of those products that we can create
and that has allowed you like what's the
best stack then for that that product
well i think we also understood how cbd
works and what it's doing it's it's
basically bringing your endocannabinoid
system back into balance for homeostasis
so endocannabinoid system right so it's
the receptors
yeah exactly exactly so cbd receptors
which is why we can take
you can take you know this is why we
love you marijuana get high because you
have a receptor
that's why we love you because you
already know all of this you already
know how all this works um
so cbd has the exact same receptors it's
cannabinoid and i'll give the
trivialized version of it is that it
connects the receptors in your own body
and brings your body back into balance
which ultimately helps with
you know stress anxiety sleep your knee
feel a little better um but tonight's
point you know that that's great but how
can we surround that experience with
something that helps you relax like we
fear our theanine or magnesium or a
hormone for sleep like melatonin how can
those things all be connected and create
a more synergistic effect so
for us the story didn't necessarily stop
with just cbd i think there's a lot of
consumer confusion like i said high
skepticism low trust on this one
ingredient that can do all of these
things which it can do it is profound
but
um for us we didn't want to really build
the story around that one ingredient it
was how can we take all these things
that create this benefit of sleep or
recovery or
uh energy and tie them all to this one
well because now it's led to the
electrolytes and to the
and to hydration which you know i
remember that conversation a while back
too and um you know you can kind of
continue that storyline of like these
are things that help you with you know
recovering with energy with
with whatever it is that you're doing
that you need a boost for and totally
regularly because i remembered i
normally wouldn't take them just on a
regular basis unless i felt like i
needed them but i remember last year
when i moved back to arizona
i
was so tired i got so tired it was right
around labor day and i was going to lake
powell with a friend and she picked me
up and i remember i just like was going
downhill that day and we went to
horseshoe bend and it was 120 out and i
was like okay cool and
they went out on the boat on lake powell
when they got there and i said i'm just
gonna stay back in the room and this is
around like hyper like even more than
right now paranoia around
covid and so um i said i'll just stay
back in the room and i thought i'm not
sick but i'm so tired
and
the next day i went out on the boat but
i drank a ton of water and i didn't go
to the bathroom much and i was like huh
and finally the day after that i felt
better and i was like holy [ __ ] i was
dehydrated i forgot
how
i forgot how easy it is to get
dehydrated in arizona because i was
working out outside in the garage in 100
degree weather and it's dry out here and
so since i've come back because i was i
got out of arizona for as much time as i
possibly could because of the heat now
that i'm back i'm like i'm gonna take
one every day because there's a lot of
science behind electrolytes too and just
how you know hydration is one thing but
the actual like cellular communication
like the network inside the body needs
the electro
lights to connect and to really like
feed the cells and feed the body with
the water and absorb it so
i've been taking them every day
that's awesome love to hear it it's
hydration somewhere cb in a way like it
hydration to some effect just keeping
your body in balance like you know your
brain function your energy all those
things are definitely linked or affected
from you know lack of hydration or being
properly hydrated
so what do you guys do i mean because
you guys are both big workout people
obviously we talk about sports we talk
about you know
silly iron mans where you do more than a
marathon which i'm training for a
marathon and i'm like you did what um i
think you have an iron man in you uh
my mind has an iron man in me but i mean
your body does it too your body does you
might brook you also talked about to
brook about it my wife brooke about it
okay okay not my sister yeah i will yeah
yeah you're gonna you're gonna you're
gonna give me some advice on on boston
because that's coming up but um but
what do you guys do and matt i mean if
anybody follows you on social media
they're like wow that bar is literally
bending when you pick it up and it's
over
how does he answer
that i mean he just laughs and goes like
you just kind of go like
just be like
i mean don't worry we can see your
muscles for those who are actually
watching like
your muscles as you lean forward there's
like you know your shirts like you
should see his quads right
yeah it's good okay um
it's fun i just got into crossfit pretty
much we started being because we got
into the crossfit community it was our
first space that we started with beam
and
that's where i started doing crossfit
kevin and dragon at a couple classes
before that but i never did it i would
just
i don't do a couple workouts on my own
do some of my hockey training maybe go
to a couple classes and then we got into
running okay i haven't got me into
running and then
thank you for everything um exactly and
then i got into crossfit just a couple
years ago and that's been my
running running crossfit but i skew more
run it very crossfit and kevin excuse
more running and endurance but
i started following a program that some
of the athletes you work with do and
probably a little too intensely but well
you look like you've been doing it
forever
you probably should compete uh in
another life it doesn't have any more
time you do from a diet standpoint are
you super regimented or how do we
how does that someone out there that
wants to be super buff with low body fat
like you um achieve that just pray yeah
is that all it takes jesus that's part
of it gotta go
um very very rarely do i eat breakfast
so i usually have um a huge thing of
water in the morning
with some electrolytes i have a packet
of greens and then i have a coffee with
collagen and mct oil and you know some
type of
ghee or grass-fed butter in it and then
i don't eat lunch once in a while i have
breakfast and i enjoy it but i really
don't eat anything until you know 12 1 2
o'clock and then i drink a ton of water
um
and then
when i'm in like a healthy focus yeah um
it's just a lot of vegetables i tried
different diets i messed around like
i've tried a vegan diet i've tried a
paleo diet i think primarily i just try
to avoid things that are processed um
but i'm not afraid to have pizza and
things that i enjoy as well so i'm
probably like 80 85 strict and then
10 to 15 i just i like to enjoy food too
what do you like don't drink a lot of
alcohol like i like to cheat on alcohol
and i love wine
yeah i would be more like pizza and
dessert would be my
my areas where i really let loose
so you can throw a dessert back yeah i
would speak to
no real secrets there
that's that does sound like a secret i
mean i mean at least it sounds like a
method i mean i think that's kind of
what people are always looking for is
what is it that gets you there and um
you know once you
survey enough then you come up with a
common nominator and i feel like
especially for men um skipping breakfast
and so look i look at it like hey you
just reduced your calories hi you just
didn't eat breakfast got it yeah um and
it probably doesn't mean that you gorge
at lunch because you didn't eat
breakfast you know so there's a
production in calories but i think
there's probably also it's also you know
there's some there's a lot of science
behind um fasting and but i do think it
works really well well for men do you do
the same thing kevin or do you i um i do
some time restricted eating stuff too my
wife brooke actually doesn't do well
with that she hates it for some reason
it makes her i think i think
hormonally there's some differences
obviously between men and women i think
that that's that's part of it on the
women's side but she feels awful when
she does it um
i go through i go through spurts with it
um
i've been i we've been kind of living in
the middle of connecticut for a little
bit uh in the middle of nowhere and i've
been doing a ton of roads cycling got
like a couple sometimes 250 200 miles a
week um
so i'm trying to figure out what's what
i want to be what i should be eating i'm
getting a little too uh skinny i'm a
work in progress i'm working on it
um and then we're gonna move back to
boston and i'm gonna stop writing so
i'll have to figure out again but
definitely i'd say
similar to that time-restricted eating i
think is
you cannot eat before i've noticed if i
can stop eating at 8pm i sleep better i
feel better in the morning um
then i if i can last past noon in the
morning or you know into the afternoon i
feel a lot better this probably you
don't need to eat as much food as you
think like you and i feel lean i have
you know that like that lean feeling
like when you just feel a little bit
tighter i feel i kind of and i like
working out when i haven't eaten yet
either on the weekends um
and even i just i literally that's why i
was a few minutes late getting on the
call i was meeting with my functional
medicine doctor and i told her that i i
don't it doesn't happen to me like
midday after like evening especially
evening but in the morning i wake up
starving
and um she's like so what she suggested
to me was
eat like a tablespoon or two of nut
butter before you go to bed to try and
help kind of stabilize and i can't wait
to do that because number one i love nut
butter but then number two i get to eat
something which is fun um and so yeah
this whole mind game that i've been
playing with myself i went around and
round about being vegan or eating less
meat
um and i did that for a while
to no pleasure avail the same i was the
same i was the same way and i could not
like there's nothing that makes me feel
better than having a grass-fed steak in
vegetables like i don't know what it is
in my dna i agree i agree i love high
fat proteins i love fat i want to not i
want to hate i want to hate meat but i
can't well and it's like you know i know
the whole argument about you know you
you have animals and so you love the
animals yet you pay for someone to kill
it so you can eat it and it's like i get
it but there is also a lot of science
behind the thought that part of like our
our growth and our brain and how our
we've evolved has to do with eating meat
and
um and i can't argue with how i feel
which means which is i feel way better
when i eat meat and so um or animal
protein so do you follow a certain kind
of diet um
not at different times in my life i'd
say like different seasons in my life if
i do this isn't one of them um honestly
like it's
not i don't i don't i'm definitely like
a lot of i don't even find food or you
know for the conventional diet i
probably have a much better diet than a
lot of people but i'm not doing like
paleo i'm trying not to eat very much in
the morning to that point i think i feel
best then but summer is so tough too
especially with everything we have going
on traveling and all that trying to be a
little bit more um i'm probably talking
about empathy i'm trying to be a little
more self-empathetic to like
my stress and everything else i have
gone and i don't need to add an
additional layer of insanity which at
times in my life i have certainly added
that layer of insanity that didn't need
to be there i was been thinking about
sacrifice and so i'm kind of curious
like what's the biggest sacrifice you
make for health and then what's the
biggest sacrifice that you have had to
make for the growth
aka health of beam
there's definitely someone watching who
knows how to read body language because
you both sat there and looked to the
left
i can't tell you
that you both looked left and went like
that i'm sure there's some part of your
brain being accessed we're searching the
depths of our brain there's not much to
search about i'm trying to think i'm
trying to answer the beam one first has
there been a compromise within beam that
you've felt like you've had to make or
maybe there hasn't been not from a
product standpoint but when i think of
that question i just i guess i just
think like personally
we've just given up a lot it just
requires a lot of sacrifice like
leadership you know there's a great one
of the episodes from michael jordan's
uh last dance documentary just he just
says like leadership has a price and
winning has a price and
you know you just have to sometimes you
have to get up people's butts and
sometimes you have to cool people along
and
it's not always fun and games and it's
really hard and i think that's i guess
like the sacrifices like you're signing
up for something that's not just like
this sunshine and balloons journey it is
this constant up and down up and down
and
um
there's a lot of sacrifice that goes
into that i don't know if i can make
sense any bigger but just constant worry
it's just the worry is just like
non-stop on everything in the business
whether it's like you know we need to
close another round of funding and you
know cash is running low or someone on a
team quit or someone on the team
is having a family issue or there's an
ingredient in a product that shouldn't
be there and it tastes like crap so we
need to have it remade or um it's just
like non-stop constant worrying that
just never goes away um
and it's uh with that you said why would
you why do you put yourself through that
if that's what it's like um
and i think we endure that because of
we're confident what we're building and
what we're doing because on the other
side of that is like you know we just
had our team retreat and just like
building these relationships like we're
you know she's building stronger
connections with people on the team and
like that part of the process and the
journey and doing stuff with people you
love
that all
outweighs all of like those dark valleys
that you go into i think as founders um
so this is not funny to make it sound at
the same time
um you and that's the sacrifices that
you endure those things the constant
stress and worrying and dealing with
people and
you know whatever
to then enjoy like building something
hopefully great with people you enjoy
doing stuff with because life is short
though like i've paid for that word
physical mental health like i feel
times and you know we talked about you
know carter has talked about this too
you know being tired and all of us it's
just like you get to a point where
you're just like you can't worry anymore
and you need to take a break and it's
just um
it's hard to describe it's hard to say
to like to put words to it but it's uh
yeah hopefully there's something good on
the other end of it yeah you just take
on the weight you're like hey look here
we go i'm going to carry this um totally
yeah it's a constant drain
um okay from uh from a from a lifestyle
standpoint like do you you know you you
don't eat cake like what do you do to
optimize your health the most
from a fitness or a nutritional
standpoint what's your sacrifice
i do more yoga i love yoga but i end up
doing more yoga than i want to because
you don't get enough like you don't get
more you don't get
a lot of bang for your buck from yoga
from my perspective i know um that's why
i don't do it most of the time people
think i love it i don't i love it but
it's just not efficient
yeah you just like
i want to feel beat up at the end and i
just can't i feel good but i don't know
i'm happy that i did it but i'm like oh
god i should still beat it up like
what's going on in her head that's
that's doing it
i want to turn that off
i don't know doctor we need a diagnosis
okay well i'm sure you have to say i'm
sure if you're the same way you have the
same feeling it's just like i yeah
i i wish that i could just be content
being like oh i feel so zen that was a
great yoga class there's my workout but
then i'm like oh [ __ ] you you you should
feel bad that you you should go work out
and do something hard you know what is
that
i don't know it's a programming
it's not good
we need to talk to tech support so i
think yoga i guess that's a kind of a
crappy answer but i think yoga i guess
why is that you i don't know i feel
yoga because you know it's good for your
mind and body but yet it doesn't feel
like i get it i do that when i'm really
tired and i don't want to work out i do
yoga same but then i'll shut up after
this but then i do the yoga and i'm like
in the yoga i'm like okay this is just
like a tired workout it's like i'm just
not gonna do yoga hard i'll just like
kind of like sleep and relax they don't
get anything out of yoga it's just a bad
mix but anyways maybe you should slept
in yoga
sounds like a mental burden you know
there's a lot that's demanded out of us
i think our mind our energy and things
like that so i think for me i naturally
i don't really gravitate towards like
drinking and partying stuff like that
but there are times it's like you know
not engaging as much social stuff just
because i know if i stay up later if i
drink or i'm just not going to feel
great in the morning and
you know like i was saying earlier like
hockey was really easy just go show up
to the gym i could shoot pucks i could
hop on the ice even if i was tired i
could still kind of do that stuff
my brain doesn't operate the same way i
can sometimes it's not as easy just to
push through so i have to like protect
my brain as if it's you know like my
muscles from playing hockey or something
so
i guess it's i sacrificed probably being
more social and doing things like that
um i haven't found a girlfriend yet but
i found that
you know that'll come in time so i think
i probably sacrificed being putting it
you don't want to be so little
i don't know he doesn't want to be
social
yeah
exactly i've cut out my social life for
kevin
well then you're in the perfect business
to have a startup okay exactly it's all
gone well so now there's no more
sacrifices everything is gangbusters the
company sells for you know the golden
billion dollars someday
um what do you do we have a happy we
have we got a call from you as a happy
investor yeah yeah yeah for sure but i'm
like i mean there's gonna but this isn't
about me but i'll still call
um
what are you gonna do like what what
what would you do with the money i mean
that would be the fun fun question i'm
sure there'd be a nice house involved in
that and probably a nice vacation of all
the people that have been involved in
the process take i think we always want
to treat people that have been helpful
supportive and take them out do
something really cool
like not yeah exactly
um
it's funny like we always thought like i
think we would very quickly start our
heads would start spinning what the next
thing would be um it sounds kind of
maybe psychotic to be thinking like that
but
you know i think it was like what's
what's a bigger and more impactful thing
that we can create now all the stuff
that we've learned through this like
we're really dumb when you started being
so you know kind of it's still large
there's a little bit less dumb now
i do know that if there was a lot of
money involved like sitting around
spending it wouldn't be maximizing my
potential so there'd be something that i
would want to do to
whether it involved probably
it sounds insane but a likely fortunate
would be putting a lot of that money
towards the new thing and having that
feeling of life literally going to do
this roll it in roll it into something
probably i think like there's just
something to be said all the painful
things that we've talked about the last
hour about like that's what that's the
beautiful thing about it too like that's
what makes it so fulfilling and like
gratifying it's like you have something
on the line and there's that um it's not
to be honest the longer this goes like
the
the outcome of like a a lot of money
isn't overly accepting like it's it's a
means to an end of course to be able to
have things that you want in life but
like
the money i don't i think it's like the
like you're chasing like the feeling of
like like having your potential
fulfilled and i think i'd want that
again
um it's like the next challenge yeah
it's really hard to like that's i think
after baseball i started doing iron
man's and it's just like there's just a
reason like it wasn't doing ironman
because i was good at them i was
thinking because like i needed to like
copy the challenge when you find the
next thing
so
i think i'd spend the money on some cool
stuff but ultimately that i don't think
that would really be
that exciting
well um that's why successful people
roll into the next successful thing so i
was gonna ask if there's like things on
your mind that you're you're curious and
spinning about like oh we could start a
company around this but that's for
another episode that's for another day
um
for now
beam is killing it and i'm super
grateful to be in the program and to
test stuff and be an investor and
help tell people how great it is so um
anybody that tries to have that's all i
know all i know is everyone that tries
it loves it so
thank you yeah you believe in us for a
long time um you know the more
successful the company is to an extent
the easier it is to believe in us as
time goes by so it's been a while and
you uh
you you voted uh very early on and i
don't think we'll ever forget that so
appreciate it
yeah thank you
thank you
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today i hope you
enjoyed it if you like what you heard
today and you want to hear more please
click on the subscribe button